our gorilla glue toughest player on
planet earth name image and likeness
deal it has been a wonderful regular
season we're about to give out our final
such award
there's one more after this which we're
going to be giving out around the
national championship game
so
this regular season award it's been a
delight meeting so many people
and we'll run down that list shortly but
our
final regular season winner
of this toughest player on planet earth
award presented by gorilla glue that
goes to a player that doesn't expect an
nil deal coming
that represents so much
for his team because of not the way that
he had just potentially balled out but
also the journey and how uh somebody can
make the most of an opportunity
so this week's winner is louisiana ragin
cajun running back amani bailey
he's from the texas area he found
himself on the bayou and he found
himself
with the ball in his hands of a tight
game in the sun belt conference
championship game against appalachian
state which is a four-letter word in my
corner of the football universe
collegiately
and he took one 385 yards to the house
to wrap it up
for the game
ceiling run career-high 117 rush yards
and 14 carries in that game
he leads the team with 6.4 yards per
carry and it was a big win for the team
because as you know
their coach and billy napier it was his
last game there
he is heading to florida
what a big stepping stone that is for
him
so
um is our
is our man on the phone line right now
christopher yes he is
all right he is our final gorilla glue
toughest player on planet earth nil
winner of the regular season here on the
rich eisen show please welcome louisiana
ragin cajun running back
imani bailly
[Applause]
i am doing fine congratulations on uh on
on getting the last spot here this year
i mean what a what a dub for your team
and uh you being a freshman to help put
the sunbelt championship out of reach
that had to be something for you huh
yeah it was a wonderful film you know i
was i was very happy
to help get the team win and we just we
just represented well and i was very
proud of that hey so uh walk me through
your 35-yard touchdown run it's 17-10
less just a little bit more than 12
minutes to go and then you hit pay dirt
what happened
so
um as the play was developing um
they were getting ready to send the
all-out blitz and i seen all seven in
the box
and um i knew how the play was gonna
develop with my tackle and my tight end
and it just opened up like the red sea
and i was able to get through and uh
make money
hey yeah
well uh yeah certainly since it uh we
you've been on our radar screen a little
bit and then this one popped so yeah
you're going to get a thousand dollars
in this nil deal i assume is this your
first nil deal of your uh life career
emanating yes
yes sir
my very first one okay well this is
great how did you get to louisiana how
did you get there tell us your
background i got there so the background
of me getting to louisiana um patrick
patrick tony
uh who was now in florida he um he
actually had called me
and i was like
uh can we get you down here for a
workout and uh to see how you you know
how you are and i came down here and uh
just basically went through the drills
and um
what they wanted to see from me and then
a couple days later they uh they gave me
an offer
and that's how you got there
yeah okay
maybe a week later i committed
okay maybe a week later you committed so
um and you're from texas originally
correct what town in texas are you from
originally
i'm i'm from texas okay benton texas
so you go to the friday night lights to
the saturday night spotlight and the sun
belt and
so who's your who's your running back
growing up who have you been growing up
saying i want to be like this guy
imani
if i had to say i i've actually had a a
lot of heroes to watch uh reggie bush
chris johnson
uh daniel thomason but if i had to
really
really just pick one it'll probably be
um
well right now yeah
saquon barkley okay
so we we've never met you are you
quadzilla too is that what you got going
on for you just like saquon or or no
i'm gonna say i got
they're not as big as his but i think i
could uh i'll get there eventually okay
right now well and chris johnson too i
mean you're you're talking about one of
the fastest men alive
emani yeah you know
all right so how fast do you run your 40
uh not a 4-2 but i i
i get myself bigger for four okay there
you go mine is five nine seven uh at my
best imani that's mine
oh you know i i love seeing it no i i
run it in the suit imani don't worry
it's just you don't have to you just run
in your raging cajun uniform what has it
been like for your team to to to hear
you know that your coach is going to
florida and then he did coach in the
sunbelt championship and you sent him
off to his new gig
with with a title uh what's it been like
around your program last couple weeks
with billy napier
uh it's been cool you know um
you know he came to us first let us know
that he was getting ready to go
and um
we we love coach nate and you know we
wanted to leave him off with a bang you
know for all the work we had done and
since from january to now
and we just wanted to continue to work
on the mission that we we started and
that's what we did
okay and now you're going to be in the
new orleans bowl uh taking on marshall
as the sun belt champions um i am
imagining with this being in new orleans
and nearby the state of texas you're
gonna have a lot of uh guests at this
bowl game i'd imagine i um i definitely
have some of a lot of folks coming in
this way okay what's the grand total
number of tickets you think you're gonna
have to work on
between now and
uh
well over maybe maybe 15 20 i imagine so
so who who's in your inner circle who
you might have called up and said hey i
got an nil deal from gorilla glue who
are those people oh emani
first and foremost my mother you know
she
she's my my hero she's the reason why i
do what i do
and um you know just calling her telling
her
it's a dream come true you know that's
what we talked about since the beginning
and his father finally fallen into place
that's great so does that mean you're
going to give her some of your free glue
and tape and stuff like that did she get
some of that oh yeah no no doubt okay
what needs fixing in your house in your
dorm room imani what needs fixing in
your world that the glue might
help
i guess i could you know
save the door a little bit
do you have your door needs fixing is
that what you said
yeah just a little bit of the door okay
well look uh you certainly went through
the gate um and out it this past weekend
and you got us
uh noticing so congratulations to you
and your family and everything that
you've been able to achieve so far and i
look forward to connecting with you as
you go about your career with the raging
cajuns imani yes sir no doubt i
appreciate it you got it amani bailey
everybody there
final regular season toughest player on
planet earth presented by gorilla glue
here on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here